well first of all for domestic health I
the issue that's crying out to be
addressed and it's going to take courage
on the part of leadership the president
and it's going to take cooperation with
the Congress it's going to take an
understanding and a na flexibility on
the part of the American public is that
we must address the fact that in this
rich country of ours we have 40 plus
million people without health care
insurance so we've got to be able to fix
that problem and fix it reasonably
quickly so that when people lose their
jobs and with it lose their health
insurance and find out that their one
job dismissal away from being completely
vulnerable to disease and getting their
savings and their family wiped out
because they don't have health insurance
we've got to fix that problem so if
you're asking me what what I would think
if the next president would ask me my
opinion of what I would think from a
domestic standpoint what we need to do
we really need to fix the health care
delivery problem in this country with
regard to universal health access to
everyone
it's not going to be easy but I think it
can be done I think that if you have a
flexible system where people can still
have the choice of the doctor that they
want if they have insurance that they
are able to pay for but that doesn't
mean that you then not allow people who
don't have the wherewithal to have
insurance that everybody has insurance
and everybody can get a doctor it may
not necessarily be the doctor of your
choice but it's a doctor that's well
trained and paid well enough to be
someone of high quality so just because
you go into a system where you're
assigned the doctor if you have people
who are well trained and well paid and
have good motivations for being in that
you can get good medical care you don't
necessarily have to then exclude those
people who want to choose their own
doctor and are willing to pay to choose
their own doctor so I think you can get
both worlds there and also there's
enough profit margin in drugs and the
development of drugs that I don't think
there's going to be an issue with the
drug companies there there will always
be the need for new medications better
medication so I don't see that as an
issue